bis er seine richtige bäume stimmen also
um ehrlich zu sein ich glaube ich habe
euch da gerade den beginn eines wäre der
sehr sehr sehr sehr schlechten freuen
uns gefällt auch netz willkommen beim
ein video ich hoffe euch jetzt tut mir
jetzt auch ausgezeichnet also ich hab
ein bisschen fluchten ein bisschen kraft
mein halt ich bin ganz leicht erkrankt
aber erzählt mich natürlich davon ab
heute trotzdem video zu drehen
eigentlich war ich auch schon längst
fertig nur ich dachte so acht kommen
heute kannst du schön ausschlafen
dresden heißt entspannt ein video hatte
einfach um halb elf als termin
es musste ich mich keine zehn jetzt auf
jeden fall gleich jetzt nicht gut und ob
seine kommentare auf jeden fall kann ja
vor ich glaube so drei wochen mein video
youtube videos mit 0 1
wenn ich schon traurig nicht immer noch
traurig so ergibt sich wer macht ein
schönes youtube video klickt einfach
kein leid und das kino gehen durch die
decke jetzt folge feiert deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht ja leck kommt man zwar
ein paar takte aufgeschrieben alec
wittenbach noch zum teil davon
und ja ich habe mir also gestern abend
auch ein paar wieder drauf gesucht und
ich schauen wir uns jetzt mal zusammen
an geist wirklich ganz kein gescheites
dabei also ich will gar nicht labern
wenn ich doch ein paar machen lasst
einfach mal doch nach oben da man sich
das ja und wir fangen jetzt ab die bank
ist in sotschi
übrigens ihr fragt euch sicherlich warum
ich immer noch zu hause bin ich bin grad
vielleicht am lernte meine prüfung
deswegen wenn es zu hause und reha zu
hause auf meine video das jetzt zum
beispiel ein altes zimmer wollte prozent
ist natürlich die frage mit welchen
fragen wir an ich hab das schon so beim
favoriten
hat jeder im bad gewesen als klar
blätter sind auf jeden fall lecker
empfehle ich einfach mal weiter liebe
zuschauer
liebe eltern ist vor allem jetzt an den
elternteil bitte drückt euren
minderjährigen achtjährigen kindern kein
iphone fläche die hand dankeschön
man sieht ja was dabei rumkommt er lässt
mir das kann ich mag und ansprechend das
war schon wieder so deprimierend ich bin
halt mittag nach hause gefahren in köln
und da sind auch immer viele schulkinder
dann unterwegs die mich dann zum teil
hat manchmal aber und da standen dann
wieder so 15-jährige um mich rum und
zwei davon hatten einfach ein besseres
handy und ich dass du das kannst du
jetzt nicht rein oder er deswegen holte
ich mir als nächste woche auch sofort
mein neues weil so gibt es nicht die
hatten beide seien richtig fertig sei
von 7 plus und einer hatte dieses ei
phone 7 in roth ganz krank ich glaube
die waren zehn oder elf oder zwölf
irgendwie so weit dass du heute machen
auch schon weiter mit dem nächsten video
und zwar ist das trampolin unsinn da bin
ich jetzt auf jeden fall mehr entspannt
[Musik]
konnte es nochmal bei hier fangen wir
mal ganz von vorne an also das größte
trampolin talent bist du jetzt nicht an
zumal ganz ehrlich sich einfach drehen
oder auch ein abstieg und dann wieder
hoch das kann jeder
und dafür gibt es dann halt auch kein
leid so tut mir ein bisschen leid aber
er hält du musst ich das ein bisschen
mehr anstrengen man denkt so wieder so
springt durch verdächtiges und dann
hallo ich muss kurz das essen den ofen
stellt kann das versuchen zu sagen du
kannst kannst du hier von ihrer bank auf
boden und besser wenn sogar stehen
geblieben
das war schlecht ich habe sie noch nicht
angeschaut mal gucken was da auf mich
zukommt
als das noch niemand gesehen hat dann
haben wir uns durch angeschaut leute so
ein video ist kein gutes vorbild
das ist auf keinen fall zu hause nach
dankeschön dann haben wir das video
first blog wirklich super typ
keine einstellung und der wird auf jeden
fall spätestens in drei tagen den
durchbruch seines lebens erleben wenn
das mal money to me er ist vielleicht
verstehst du mich ja du kannst doch kein
youtube video hochladen einfach sagen
abonniert mich sagt mir was ich machen
soll das ist ja ich dachte machten bis
ich dachte konnte irgendwas lustige
komme auf youtube geht es darum kreativ
zu sein coole videos zu machen und nicht
zu sagen abonniert mich ich kann gar
nichts und sagt ja auch noch was sich
hochladen soll am besten strecken ganzes
glück für meine videos alles klassiker
aber leute von bargeld sowie drei
perfekt so entkommen auch schon zum
nächsten video und zwar heißt das
gateway sich auf jeden fall super
interessant für mich wollen als
schwierige sagt keine deutschen oder
richtige bäume stünden also im ernst zu
sein
ich glaube ich habe euch da gerade die
beginn eines wäre der reserve schlechten
freuen uns gezeigt warum das dann nur
leicht verstehe ich nicht also leute
schon kommen
nach meinem video 3000 leicht auf das
video sind locker drin
jörg butt der eine typ der letztens in
mein fenster video war also instagram
bilder mit nur leicht hat jetzt einfach
moment auch das bild das in meinem video
war sind jetzt einfach 1661 like durch
ein scheiß video wo ich gesagt habe er
leute kommen leicht das mal das ist so
heftig wenn ich also wirklich also das
muss man sagen danke leute ist ein echt
mega mega krasse community also
vielleicht mal dazu ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen sind auch ein paar platz
nur nach oben da ziehe ich auf jeden
fall plätze von instagram ab und wir
sehen unseren sonntag wieder muss noch
mehr gas sie lernen ich habe zwei
prüfungen freien lauf